nos dicen linda no está segura de cómo
restar 853 menos 283 ayuda a linda a
elegir una expresión que resulte igual a
853 menos 283 pausa en el vídeo y tratan
de responder esto por su cuenta antes de
que lo resolvamos juntos muy bien al ver
todas las opciones nos damos cuenta de
que todas comienzan con 853 en la
primera opción a 853 le restan 200 lo
que tiene sentido porque aquí tenemos
dos centenas luego restan 50 y después
restan 3 tanto las dos centenas como el
3 tienen sentido podemos ver 853 menos
283 como 853 menos 200 menos 88 decenas
menos 3 pero esto no es lo que
escribieron aquí en lugar de tener 80
hay 50 por lo que podemos descartar esta
opción en la segunda opción tenemos 800
53 menos 20 menos 800 menos 3 esto es un
poco extraño porque no tenemos dos
decena
tenemos dos centenas y no tenemos ocho
centenas sino ocho decenas esta opción
también es incorrecta es probable que la
opción correcta sea esta pero vamos a
comprobarlo
ésta tiene 853 menos 200 menos 53 menos
30 tiene sentido esto pensemos en ello
lo que están haciendo es restar primero
las dos centenas que es esta parte de
aquí por lo que tiene sentido primero
restan esto luego restan 53 y después
restan 30 bueno esto es lo mismo que
restar 83 porque al restar 83 es lo
mismo que restar primero 53 y después
restar 30 53 más 30 es igual a 83 y
quizás se pregunten por qué se
molestaron en poner esto de esta forma
pues porque es más fácil resolver esto
mentalmente 853 menos 200 653 a esto le
quitamos 53 y nos queda a 600 y 600
menos 30 podemos verlo como 60 decenas
menos tres decenas lo que es igual a 50
decenas o quizá lo pueden resolver
mentalmente 600 menos 30 es igual a 570
es por esto que se descompuso el 83 en
lugar de descomponerlo como 83 lo
descompusieron como 53 y 30 para
coincidir con el 53 de acá y que fuera
más fácil calcular el resultado hagamos
otro ejemplo aquí nos piden completar el
espacio en blanco
tenemos 143 menos 79 es igual a espacio
en blanco menos 80 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo aquí lo importante
es darse cuenta de que cuando aquí
tenemos una diferencia siempre que
sumemos o restemos la misma cantidad en
ambos lados la diferencia será la misma
aquí parece que tratan de convertir el
79 en 80 agregando un 1 y si queremos
que la diferencia sea la misma entonces
tenemos que sumar 1 al 143 también por
lo que tenemos que 143 más uno es igual
a 144 si sumamos un 1 a estos dos
números entonces la diferencia será la
misma estamos listos
144 menos 80 con esto terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo